this video filmed by tuar rebels shows
what's left of the UN peacekeeping base
in aalok in Northern Mali under attack
un troops destroyed their own equipment
to prevent armed groups from stealing it
in a statement the world body says the
withdrawal is taking place under
extremely tense security conditions with
soldiers forced to shelter in bunkers
due to gunfire of the un's 12 permanent
military bases half have already closed
down and are now held by Al-Qaeda
Fighters or taric Rebels Maly Juna
accuses the peacekeepers of compromising
security by leaving too soon and failing
to hand over their bases to the malan
Army this time the malan government
basically asked everybody to leave first
the French anti-terror Mission last year
now the UN peacekeeping Force the
country is
isolated uh it's it's hard to see who
might come to mari's rescue this time
and everybody is basically praying that
the conflict won't you know turn to
larger instability in the region afraid
of what's to come many people have
already left the UN says thousands of
malians in the north are on the Move
seeking refuge in morania neighboring
countries including Sagal have increased
border surveillance fearing the violence
in Mali could spread across the
region the military government is
counting on its cooperation with Russia
a convoy of former Vagner Fighters and
malan soldiers is heading north to
recapture the UN peacekeeping
bases recently 18 people were killed
including children and elderly people
the Russian Wagner group supported by
mali's Army slaughtered
them armed Fighters are preparing for a
showdown with the malan and Russian
forces as the UN leaves moli appears to
be spiraling into Civil War Nicholas
Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer